bonsoir à toutes et tous et merci de
nous rejoindre sur tv fil 78 pour un
nouveau débat consacré à la mobilisation
sur la loi travail le ton est monté la
semaine dernière entre le medef et la
cgt après les propos polémiques de
pierre gattaz qui avait qualifié les
grévistes je cite de terroristes
même si le patron des patrons a depuis
retiré ce terme qui l'a jugée
inappropriée toujours une citation de
pierre gattaz le climat se tend entre
partisans du retrait de la loi et et
tenant d'une ligne de fermeté
malgré l'euro de football qui approche à
grands pas et les inondations qui
frappent le pays depuis une semaine les
mobilisations se poursuivre pour un
retrait de la loi travail quelle est
l'ampleur de la mobilisation quels sont
les secteurs qui sont touchés va-t-on
vers une sortie de crise l'euro de
football et les inondations vont ils
mettre un coup d'arrêt aux mobilisations
et enfin quelle conséquence une
poursuite des greffes auraient-elles sur
l'économie du territoire pour débattre
de ce sujet trois invités autour de la
table sonia porot bonsoir ça vous êtes
secrétaire départemental cgt donc pour
les yvelines une lutte miserait bonsoir
on soit un membre du bureau
départemental du parti communiste
français des yvelines et puis conseiller
communautaire à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines donc pour le
front de gauche et enfin bertrand
degrémont soir sort vous êtes président
du medef donc yvelinois 2009 78 alors
pour commencer se soigne à port aux eaux
en est on de la mobilisation dans les
yvelines dans 50 et un nul ne serait que
dans les yeux plus largement quelles
sont les points chauds entre guillemets
on a une mobilisation qui reste très
forte depuis depuis quatre mois
dans de nombreux secteurs bien sûr là
actuellement c'est le secteur des
cheminots qui est particulièrement
mobilisée parce que l'accord à la sncf
et la convention collective reprennent
d'ailleurs un certaine logique de la loi
travail donc évidemment ils sont en
grève reconductible depuis le 1er juin
et j'ai participé à plusieurs ag où la
participation est importante le vote de
la reconduction se fait de manière très
très majoritaire j'ai pas encore vu de
votre compte donc un secteur évidemment
très très mobilisé
mais on a aussi ses créations pas
uniquement sur la loi travail non pas
uniquement sur lui nous oui mais mais
aussi sur la loi travail puisque
évidemment le code du travail et des
règles qui vont s'appliquer à tous les
salariés ça concerne tout le monde quel
que soit le statut
on a également une forte mobilisation
dans le secteur de l'énergie
la centrale thermique de porcheville
alors ça c'est plus dans le nord du
département et mais qui est qui est très
mobilisée mais les sites par exemple un
amour pas ont connu également des
actions et puis après on a tout un tout
une mobilisation dans des entreprises du
privé des des magasins des maisons de
retraite alors évidemment pas des grèves
aussi aussi longue que d'autres secteurs
mais c'est très mobilisés et puis là il
ya un très gros mouvement pour faire la
votation citoyenne permettent aux
salariés de s'exprimer sur sur la loi
travaille donc avec deux questions très
simples vous êtes vous pour ou contre le
retrait de la loi travail
etes-vous pour des droits nouveaux pour
les salariés parce que la cgt et les
autres organisations syndicales qui se
mobilisent contre le projet de loi sont
aussi là pour proposer le seul retrait
du projet de loi
ça c'est pas une situation qui est
satisfaisante en tant que tel et donc on
a vraiment là des centaines de salariés
qui votent à edf dans l'automobile
dans plein de secteurs et puis on
constate aussi en parallèle et depuis le
mouvement un fort regain d'adhésions à
la cgt alors vous le parler un instant
de la cgt évidemment que vous
représentez une chaise vide juste en
face de vous nous avions invité la cfdt
des événements venez en débattre avec
nous ils ont refusé de venir débattre
alors bertrand degrés cela fait trois
mois maintenant que les mobilisations
contre la loi travaux ont commencé dans
quel état d'esprit sont les patrons
yvelinois que vous représentez après
trois mois
tout d'abord eu votre entrée en matière
pierre gattaz s'est excusé du mot
terroriste pas du mot voyou on allait
revenir
il a été très clair là dessus très
classe e terroriste parce que face aux
mondes une 13 novembre il s'était ça
peut choquer sensibilité donc il a
retiré ce moore dans un communiqué de
presse
mais pas celui de voyous jeannot compris
certaines ou non c'est bien un peu
différent alors les patrons mais ils
sont atterrés aujourd'hui sont atterrés
il faut bien savoir quand même que
aujourd'hui tous les mouvements sont des
mouvements de façade
la loi elle connerie ne les touche pas
quand on parle la sncf de les df déterra
exhumant rien on est sur une défense de
posture très clairement de la part des
syndicats
nous les patrons de pme et de tpe
je veux dire c'est le dialogue social et
95 entreprises n'ont pas syndicats ils
sont pas présents chez nous ils ne nous
connaissent pas ne savent pas comment
nous travaillons mais nous sommes la
france
nous sommes le peuple français
aujourd'hui la france est un pays de tpe
et de pme d'artisans le cac 40
on nous emmerde avec tout ça
régulièrement c'est par définition 40
entreprises terminé nommé 80 au medef
soit 95,3 d'entreprise du medef au moins
de 50 salariés
alors vous arrêtez moi personnellement
je suis président du medef sur les
yvelines
j'ai moins de 40 salariés je connais
nominativement tous les perses tout mon
personnel et on vit une histoire
formidable je n'ai jamais licencié fait
encore une fois
les patrons que je connais ceux qui sont
mes adhérents ont tous quasiment étaient
des salariés
moi j'ai été ouvrier j'ai gagné le smig
j'ai été licencié j'ai été aux
prud'hommes et puis j'ai pas suivi les
syndicats j'avais d'autres voies j'ai
choisi de créer ma boîte quand j'étais
jeune je les crée j'ai développé au joug
d'une société mais des employés mais je
me souviens que j'ai été ouvrier
soucieux j'ai gagné smic je me souviens
de tout ça et aujourd'hui les patrons
français c'est ceux-là les vrais patrons
qui font la france c'est cela cela on
n'en parle jamais jamais nous n'avons le
droit à la parole
alors il ya une espèce de d'apparatchiks
qui sont veux pas dire par l'océanic a
pas de politique qui discute entre deux
tâches choses-là des ronds pour parler
des grèves à les df ou d accord qu il
faut défendre sncf ne brille c'est tout
donc aujourd'hui le patron ils sont
exaspérés c'est le peuple français qui
exaspérés ont première 3 millions
d'hommes 3 millions de personnes
avant de répondre soigné pour une
première réaction luc miserait sur sur
ce qui vient d'être dit les patrons sont
atterrés oui enfin déjà moyens quelque
chose que je comprends pas mais c'est
effectivement pas mon problème mais
c'est la constitution du medef parce que
quel lien effectivement alors pour une
part je vais je vais je vais vous
rejoindre quel lien il y a entre les tpe
pme et les très grosses entreprises mais
aucun aucun si ce n'est que les
problèmes de nombre de tpe et de pme
ce sont les donneurs d'ordre et les
donneurs d'ordre ce sont précisément les
entreprises du cac 40 ou celles qui sont
juste en dessous et c'est donc la
problématique de l'économie et c'est là
où est le problème c'est que cette loi
c'est une loi de régression sociale
c'est pas une oie travail c'est une loi
de précarisation du travail et donc
c'est dans ce sens là qu'il ya des
solidarités qui s'exprime parce que tout
le monde sait très bien que par delà
cette loi ça touchera d'autres secteurs
d'activité donc la problématique
vous dites que la majorité des gens
ne sont pas concernées de seconde sont
pas concernés mais ce qu'on entend aussi
c'est que la majorité des gens sont
contre cette loi parce que précisément
c'est une loi de régression du travail
sur l'économie réelle qu'il faille
travailler sur l'économie réelle
que des entreprises gagnent de l'argent
c'est légitime là où on n'est pas
d'accord c'est sur la redistribution
là où on n'est pas d'accord c'est quand
et entreprises et il y en a un certain
nombre que vous connaissez mieux que moi
gagne plus d'argent par leurs placements
financiers que parra par le
développement de leurs activités
donc nous on est pour le développement
de l'activité
on a besoin d'entreprises privées et
dynamique
on a besoin en même temps de respect de
la démocratie à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise
quand vous dites à juste titre que dans
nombre d'entreprises ya pas de syndicat
mais il faut savoir aussi quand même que
quand il y en a il ya un nombre
d'entreprises où ils se font virer parce
qu'ils sont syndiqués ça existe aussi
donc et pour cent de ces indications en
france contre un peu plus tôt oui mais
dans le même temps
dans le même temps il ya des tas de gens
qui syndiqués qui se font licencier
parce qu'il syndic donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui n'est pas assez répété juste
un mot sur monsieur gates pas il peut
retirer le mot terroriste il l'a dit
donc c'est gravissime
de même qu'il a parlé pour la cgt deux
dictatures staliniennes le fort fort
heureusement pour lui et pour nous on ne
sait pas ce que c'est de la dictature
stalinienne
parce que sinon ils l'emploi aurait pas
comme ça ce sont des propos très graves
et ça nous fait penser quand même que il
ya 80 ans et veulent front populaire et
que dans le front populaire
il n'y a pas de parallèle à faire mais
il ya quand même des choses à regarder
et à cette époque là il ya un nombre de
patrons pas la totalité des patrons qui
disait mieux vaut hitler que le front
populaire
donc soyons vigilants soyons vigilants
parce que les dérives les dérives sont
là et les dérives c'est toujours les
extrémistes qui les récupèrent alors
sonia pour justement peut-être aussi sur
le vocabulaire qui a été utilisé
bertrand desprez et à la spatule et les
patrons sont atterrés peut-être que la
plupart des patrons pensent aussi comme
pierre gattaz sont osés vraiment le dire
a prôné sur de la terminologie certes
sur le mot terrorisme qu'il le retire
mais laisse toujours les termes de
voyous sont des prises d'otages des des
français etc etc
ce sont des propos d'une extrême d'une
extrême gravité
évidemment là encore que ce soit
terroriste voyous preneurs d'otages
c'est vraiment un manque un manque de
respect total pour toutes les personnes
qui subissent réellement des prises
d'otages ou ou du terrorisme mais je
pense que si le medef on est à employer
des discours aussi caricaturaux c'est
bien c'est bien qu'il ya un isolement
que 70% de la population en france et
contre ce projet de loi c'est un soutien
massif y compris encore maintenant
malgré des grèves
voilà qui qui dure malgré un certain
nombre de manifestations dans les rues
d'initiatives dans les quartiers dans
les villes donc ce soutien là il est
massif
les patrons sont majoritairement dans
les tpe et les pme les salariés aussi
hélas célérier la cgt et aux côtés de
l'ensemble des salariés et notamment
ceux des très petites entreprises on
organise demain le deuxième journée
portes ouvertes pour les salariés des
tpe de 17h à 20h dans nos locaux rue
jean jaurès à trappes
hier on a organisé une réunion pour les
salariés des hôtels cafés restaurants et
il y avait des témoignages qui étaient
extrêmement extrêmement intéressant sur
le comportement des employeurs je mets
pas tout le monde dans le même sac mais
y compris dans des petites ou moyennes
entreprises
on peut trouver
des patrons qui vont installer une
caméra en face du local syndical ou des
choses comme ça donc effectivement là le
dialogue social ça veut dire aussi qu'on
respecte les droits des salariés et de
leurs représentants qu'on facilite
effectivement l'implantation des
syndicats est une des choses qu'on
propose à la cgt pour contrer la loi
travail c'est bien des droits
supplémentaires pour les représentants
du personnel parce que si on veut faire
du dialogue dans l'entreprise
on n'est pas contre mais aujourd'hui il
ya déjà un certain nombre de
négociations obligatoires sur lesquels
les employeurs ne jouent pas le jeu ne
donne pas les enfants bien vos réponses
et sert mercoire de créer une fois n'est
pas coutume je suis absolument d'accord
avec madame port ou quand les qu'il faut
respecter les droits des salariés saison
convaincu toutefois alors vous avez une
réponse de dire qu'est ce que c'est le
medef vous posez des questions de notre
positionnement d'enseignement aux
entreprises de france donc il représente
les entreprises de france
et si vous prenez l'insee ils vous
regardent et la classification de
l'insee je crois que ça doit être 96 %
des françaises ont bondi salariés donc
on se retrouve au medef
alors quel est le lien avec le cac40 de
les grands donneurs d'ordre bien moi je
vous dis quand j'ai choisi de m'engager
c'était au medef j'ai préféré le medef
en disant justement je serai
syndicalistes et je travaillerai pour
justement avoir un rôle et j'étais
partie de ceux qui ont créé le comité
pme au medef et qui est dirigée
aujourd'hui par thibault lanxade et qui
justement créé ce lien et pour éviter
les dérives dont vous parliez et qui
sont verrait elle qui sont réels mais
par la négociation et par le travail
qu'on les résoudra tout comme jeudi à
madame poro je suis pas du tout il n'y
qu'à liste au contraire le dialogue
social
j'y crois c'est ce que je fais au
quotidien avec des salariés dans mon
entreprise et une par contre quand on
dit wanyou pas terroriste voyous
simplement c'est que la violence
non mais c'est quoi c'est la violence
sans utiliser la violence utilisée
aujourd'hui vous parler d'un
restaurateur pas des restaurateurs jeu
ces restaurateurs adhérents il élève
medef
il me dit voilà il a publié ce pauvre
homme il est face à une gâche une gare
quête à versailles
c'est le gars pour ne pas la citer elles
déversent des flots de touristes
je vais le voir il me dit écoute le
couvert mais ici la taille moyenne c'est
140 160 couverts jour
il est donc les salariés pour ça aujourd
hui la gare elle est fermée y'a pas un
japonais pas un chinois papa par les
touristes étrangers
j'ai fait 28 couverts bertrand j'étais
28 couverts
c'est une c'est porter atteinte grave
alors que ce brave homme
il est juste restera toile des salariés
il est pas dans le conflit mais le
conflit lui fait perdre du chiffre
d'affaires car cela serait une bonne
remarque attendant on va laisser deux
autres invités à répondre sur sa sur ce
restaurateur par exemple sonia porot
huit médecins qui lui concrètement va
perdre du chiffre d'affaires pas perdre
il va peut-être obligé d'être enfin
peut-être obligés de licencier
qu'est ce que vous répondez à sa main
qui regardent réellement le contenu de
la loi travail et les conséquences
qu'elle aura pour les salariés et ceux
des petites entreprises seront
particulièrement concerné puisqu'un
certain nombre de dispositions comme
l'extension du forfait jour pour les 4
par exemple pourront être passées même
sans accord collectif donc qu'ils
regardent et qui comprenne pourquoi
c'est ses salariés là sont mobilisés
parce que le secteur de la restauration
c'est aussi un des secteurs où on trouve
le plus d'heures supplémentaires non
payées ou ayant un certain nombre de
travailleurs sans papiers et la cgt les
accompagne pour leur régularisation qui
sont employés et c'est aussi tout ce
système est l'acte mais la question
c'est pas votre entreprise à vous
comment ça se passe quand le vécu
globale des salariés et la violence les
salariés la subissent aussi la violence
de pas pouvoir partir en vacances la
violence ne pas pouvoir boucler les fins
de mois
la violence ne pas savoir est ce qu'ils
vont garder leur boulot que ce soit en
cdi ou un cdd
aujourd'hui de là pour discuter
physiquement je suis attendu mais david
a passé j'étais discutons moi je suis
prêt à ouvrir si vous trouvez un patron
qui court du mal qui se conduit mal je
vous donne mon engagement je m'engage
mois président du medef aller avec vous
le voir et lui faire la leçon
c'est bien ça c'est le début c'est un
début de solution vous êtes vous allez
avoir du boulot
il était là pour travailler justement
bien sûr va on va invoquer
et puis je vous donne la parole tout de
suite les qui miserait c'est françois
hollande qui a invoqué maurice thorez en
disant il faut savoir arrêter une grève
alors il a cité que la moitié du propos
la vraie situation c'est des cons a
obtenu satisfaction mais s'est arrêté à
il faut savoir arrêter une grève d'oc il
faut savoir arrêter c'était le message
qu'il vous donne à vous parti communiste
français qui est peut-être le seul parti
politique en france qui est opposé et
qui est pour l'heure étroits de cette
loi pour front de gauche compris bien
sûr
ou bien la cgt ou d'autres syndicats du
cuisant il a tout à fait le pouvoir de
l'arrêté la grève demain s'il veut c'est
très simple il retire un projet doigt
parce que pour l'instant c'est qu'un
projet de loi qui requiert une
opposition de l'immense majorité des
français et des françaises
donc c'est très simple dont qu'il le
fasse sur air sur le préfet non avec le
dos de nom mais voilà les choses
et peuvent être simples je vais revenir
là dessus mais quand même
effectivement il ya une différence entre
le terme de voyous monsieur gattaz est
libre d'utiliser le terme de voyous il a
le droit
le terme de terroriste c'est une
rencontre extrêmement oui mais ça suffit
pas je ne suis pas fort l'admets mais
les voyous et les délinquants
il ya aussi de la délinquance en col
blanc parce que les problèmes de notre
économie
on est en train de par exemple souvent
on entend de le problème majeur des
entreprises c'est les charges
bon d'accord le problème c'est un des
problèmes
un des problèmes majeurs françois
hollande s'était engagé à le faire il
l'a pas fait c'est une véritable réforme
fiscale dans ce pays et y compris pour
les entreprises c'est à dire que de
moins pénaliser les entreprises qui
emploient et de plus pénaliser les
entreprises qui gagnent leur argent en
cliquant sur une souris et en faisant
des placements financiers
donc j'aurai vous donc bien mais c'est
une énorme réforme fiscale à mettre en
place les problèmes d'évasion fiscale
par exemple mais qui organise le plus
l'évasion fiscale il ya de quelques
particuliers etc
oui ils sont à dénoncer mais ça sur la
masse de l'évasion fiscale tu porte
préjudice à la france et bien c'est
essentiellement certaines entreprises
effectivement les tpe etc certaines
entreprises donc là il ya des ressources
financières
ce gouvernement hollande valls macron à
à exonérer de 40 milliards
il faut se rappeler sur la base d'une
parole de monsieur gattaz gilles doucet
données dont ceux-ci domaine où cela et
on créer un million d'emplois
ils leur ont donné à tort à mon avis et
le résultat c'est que le million
d'appels refont il est pas rigolo on va
donc les voyous en col blanc existe
aussi
il faut que ce soit dit alors il ya une
pression qui est mise par les politiques
en ce moment
si je sais pas si vous avez remarqué sa
dernière sortie médiatique la main après
le coeur de monsieur sarkozy que jean
sorti mes mouchoirs avec l'euro qui
commence le 10 juin est également les
inondations bien sûr l'un penser à
toutes les familles qui ont été touchées
par les inondations mais des inondations
sont également rentrés dans le débat sur
la loi travail je vous propose d'écouter
la présidente du conseil régional de
d'île de france valérie pécresse
aujourd'hui le sujet il est simple c'est
que moi je demande solennellement
grévistes de la sncf
par esprit de solidarité et avec 70
parlementaires de toute l'ile-de-france
tous les parlementaires des ivy le
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines
je demande de suspendre la grève parce
qu'on ne peut pas ajouter de la galère à
la galère et que quand toute l'île de
france est en vrac
quand les franciliens sont vraiment dans
la détresse c'est vraiment pas le moment
de défendre des revendications
catégorielles la grève où il c'est
possible c'est un droit c'est
constitutionnel mais pas en somme sonia
porot on ne peut pas ajouter de la
galère à la galère elle parle clairement
senti sentimentalisme nous avons mais
voilà elle parle directement aux
grévistes pensez aux familles qui ont
été inondées qui sont dans la difficulté
il faut suspendre le mouvement depuis
après vous pourrez reprendre plus tard
et parmi ces personnes touchées raya y
compris des salariés
en grève et la galère il y en aura
beaucoup plus est pour beaucoup plus
longtemps si c'est un projet comme la
loi travail passe moi je suis amusé à
chaque fois qu'il ya un mouvement voilà
de grève des mobilisations de salariés
ben oui on redécouvre que ceux qui font
les richesses que ceux qui font
fonctionner le pays que ceux qui font
rouler les trains qui font tourner les
magasins ou autres
bah oui ce sont ce sont les salariés
vous nous dites voilà le ce sont les
entrepreneurs qui font le pays sans
salarié il ya ya ya rien qui fonctionne
et on s'en rend compte
je veux dire la cgt a toujours porter
des valeurs de solidarité et notamment
on a une association l'avenir social qui
portent des projets de solidarité
internationale mais qui intervient et
organisent des collectes à chaque fois
qu'il ya des événements naturels ou des
catastrophes en france donc comme à
chaque fois on va on va être on va être
solidaires mais on est toujours aussi
mobilisés et moi j'aimerais bien que la
cgt fassent la pluie et le beau temps
mais c'est pas nous par exemple savoir
c'est pouvoir alors berton d'ocré
justement parce qu'avec eux on a parlé
d'une ovation mais également de l'euro
leur trouble qui arrive qui était censé
être en tout cas un élément qui
dynamisent l'économie du pays et du coup
vous voyez ça comme voile à l'école
ça me fallait être compliqué pour les
entrepreneurs les freins qui seront mis
toutes les jeunes qui se sont mis et
tous deux seront perdus ce qu'ils font
la tête 1-0 père grève qui seront perdus
du fait de la grèce aux euros perdus
pour l'économie française
pour l'entrepreneur et donc pour les
salariés mais moi je vais rebondir ce
pauvre madame pour ses quelque part
c'est que les rumeurs dont je vous parle
on est loin des stock options des allées
cac 40 de ces tpe et pme
on est très loin de ses salaires là on
est sur des hommes qui ont investi
qu'ils se soient pas payés pendant des
années qui après peut-être récolte des
fruits in n je veux dire j'ai pas le
bouquin personnel mon entreprise je la
transmets un message à amon ra monfils
la transmet sable quoi que je la vendrai
jamais logement shihri jamais
je la vendrai pas mais aussi ça fait
quoi si j'avais vendu à grands groupes
d'édition joindre le carrefour ou à
quelqu'un il aurait le droit ou pleurer
reprise aurait pu la péter changé et
salariés l'orval transition douce on va
respecter les emplois aidés travail et
cissac tous où l'on nous les
entrepreneurs de france s'est développé
nos boss s'est assuré la mère de famille
c'est ce que nous voulons avec nos
salariés avec non salariés c'est une
histoire qu'on vit ensemble et je refuse
qu'on nous met dans un camp adversaire
moi je suis avec mes salariés je
travaille avec eux au quotidien je les
écoute que dia est pourquoi l écart
entre chez nous et parce que justement
dans une boîte comme la mienne est un
tout et boîtes de france où ne sont pas
les 95 % ne sont pas c'est que viviane
laporte
il tape et on dit entrée est là et l'art
et la jav dans l'aujourd'hui ce que la
loi calque aubry pourra apporter de très
fort et ce que nous demandons nous pme
tpe
ce que nous demandons c'est d'avoir la
possible de négocier avec une hausse
allant l'entreprise et dans l'entreprise
pourquoi dans cette rivière de branches
de gens qui ne nous connaissent pas qui
sont négociés par des grands groupes ce
qui a causé sa part desai la cgt life au
2nd été frappé par ce n'est pas
personnel mais des syndicats qui ne sont
pas chez nous ils ne connaissent pas
avec des hommes qui nous connaissent pas
et dont on doit appliquer ça chez nous
après c'est insensé
l'udc ne miserait ce sera votre peau de
conclusion plutôt pessimiste ou
optimiste pour une sortie de crise de
cette mobilisation sur la loi travail ça
chez moi je me livre pas aux pronostics
mais je vais rebondir sur
ce que vous disiez à l'instant
précisément s'il ya eu un code du
travail mais ça a été pour protéger les
salariés des abus qu'ils ont subis et
donc là quand je parle de régression
sociale mais c'est justement ça parce
que comme on inverse et que dans
l'entreprise
mais qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
mais on le voit bien
écoutez on va faire une consultation
d'accord 1
soit vous acceptez d'augmenter votre
temps de travail de faire des heures
supplémentaires qui seront pas payés ou
alors on licencie quelle est la
négociation là dedans
donc oui mais vous dites ça se passe pas
comme ça mais ça se passe on aussi comme
ça donc le existe aussi donc l'objet
s'est précisée le code du travail
il a été fait pour protéger les salariés
des abus qu'ils ont subis
si on inverse la case le processus on
revient là dessus et donc on repère mais
ça bat tout le monde que tout moi je ne
mets pas tous les patrons dans le maine
il nya qu on aurait jamais dans ma
bouche le terme de patrons parce que son
absence vouloir se voit là le dialogue
le dialogue ou go comme vous avez fait
ce soir en tout cas merci à tous les
trois d'avoir participé à ce débat
c'était très intéressant on aurait pu
encore parlé beaucoup plus longtemps que
ça mais le temps est compté merci à
toutes les équipes techniques de tv fil
78 et je ne sais pas à réagir sur le
twitter de l'émission hashtags est une
société ou à visiter le site tv fil 78
points comme bonne suite de programmes
et bonne soirée sur tv fil 78